.
* Kuhglocken *
Heia!
Hey, hopp!
Hey, hey!
* Kuhglocken *
Heia-hopp!
Ich war schon öfters dabei,
wenn eine Kuh kalbte.
Ich denke,
wenn es auf natürlichem Weg kommt,
schaffen das die meisten Leute.
Nein, nicht die meisten, alle.
Wir haben ja einen Instinkt,
der dann einsetzt.
Jetzt schläft es. Es weiss, dass das
Bettchen am richtigen Ort ist.- Ja.
Jetzt ist es zufrieden, was?
* Sanfte Klänge *
* Schmerzvolles Stöhnen *
Es ist schon hart ...
... zuzuschauen, wie es ihr ...
... so schlecht geht.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Komm, Kira, komm.
Komm. Ich gebe euch
ein bisschen Salz. Kommt.
Diese Steigung ist anstrengend.
Ich merke, dass ich ausser Atem bin.
* Keuchen *
Ich nehme es gemütlich.
Eliane Haldi ist unterwegs
in einen neuen Lebensabschnitt.
In ein paar Monaten
wird sie zum ersten Mal Mutter
und gleichzeitig Bäuerin
auf einem Hof im Saanenland.
Ich freue mich darauf.
Letzten Sommer
haben wir die Scheune umgebaut.
Das war toll und ich freue mich
darauf, den Hof zu bewirtschaften.
Wir sind dabei,
unsere Zukunft aufzubauen.
Ich freue mich.
Ich war schon immer
ein Bauernmädchen,
nun werde ich eine Bauernfrau.
Diesen Bauernhof in Saanenmöser
will sie künftig
mit ihrem Verlobten bewirtschaften.
Das Kind
soll in der Natur aufwachsen.
Ja, wenn das Kind ...
Es soll nicht immer drinnen sein
und vor dem Fernseher sitzen
oder mit dem Handy herumspielen.
Es soll sich eher draussen
in der Natur aufhalten,
so wie wir das
als Kinder gemacht haben.
Na, Butzeli, habt ihr Hunger?
Ich bringe euch Milch.
Das ist das Kalb
meines Rinds Ladina.
Ich war zufällig bei der Geburt
dabei und half ein bisschen mit.
Dabei dachte ich: "So wird es mir
wahrscheinlich auch gehen."
Ich war schon öfters dabei ...
... wenn eine Kuh kalbte.
Ich erlebte das schon als Kind mit.
Daher habe ich
eigentlich keine Angst davor.
Für mich ist es anders
als z.B. für einen Stadtmenschen,
der keine Ahnung hat,
wie eine Geburt abläuft.
Na, Wuschel?
Auch Marco hat Erfahrung
mit Schwangerschaft und Geburt.
Wie Eliane hofft auch er,
er werde sie dereinst nutzen können.
Wir sind alle Säugetiere.
Die Dimension
ist sicher eine andere ...
... aber ansonsten
läuft es ziemlich ähnlich ab.
Kühe haben halt vier
anstatt zwei Beine.
Komm.
He, komm, steh jetzt auf. Komm.
* Marco lacht. *
Es ist lustig,
es herumrennen zu lassen.
Aber man muss es wieder einfangen.
- Das tue ich jeden Tag.
Komm.
* Marco pfeift. *
Mit Milch kann man ihn locken.
Der Wolf ist tagsüber
ja nicht unterwegs.- Nein.
Bald soll hier
ihr gemeinsames Kind herumtollen.
Auch in Sachen Erziehung
haben die zwei bereits Vorwissen.
Kannst du es ihm anziehen?
- Ich halte ihn.
Das Geburtshaus Maternité Alpine
in Zweisimmen.
Hier bringen viele Frauen
aus der Region ihre Kinder zur Welt.
Die Geburtenabteilung
im Spital nebenan
wurde vor ein paar Jahren
geschlossen.
(Frau) Hallo.
* Das Baby greint. *
Wollen wir dich wiegen?
Hebamme Chantal Boschung
engagiert sich mit Leib und Seele
für das Geburtshaus.
Vieles hier oben
ist anders als in einem Spital.
Ihr Job ist vielseitig ...
... und die Atmosphäre im Geburtshaus
familiär.
Das Abendessen für die Wöchnerin.
Heute gibt es
Kraftsuppe und Risotto.
Du hast dich schon angepasst.
Du übernimmst
die Methode der Köchin.
Man hat hier wirklich
keine andere Möglichkeit.
Nach Thun zu fahren ...
- Nur schon die Strecke.
Ja, nur schon die Strecke.
Zudem ticken die Leute dort
einfach anders.
Willkommen.
- Hallo.
Auch Eliane und Marco wollen ihr Kind
in der Maternité zur Welt bringen.
Ich bin Chantal.
- Ich bin Eliane. Freut mich.
Ich bin Marco.
- Hallo zusammen.
Du darfst deinen Bauch auspacken.
Super.
Ich habe etwas kühle Hände,
aber ich wärme sie bei dir auf.
Bitte sag es mir,
wenn ich dir wehtue.
Ihr Baby ist jetzt 22 Wochen alt.
Die Gebärmutter ...
* Schneller,
rhythmischer Herzschlag *
Es fühlt sich pudelwohl.
- (Lachend) Ja.
Das ist schön zu hören.
So weiss ich,
dass es lebt und gesund ist.
Das ist ein schönes Gefühl.
* Rhythmischer Herzschlag *
Ja, es klingt gesund.
Zufrieden und gesund.
Gut.
Landwirt Marco brilliert beim Besuch
im Geburtshaus mit Fachwissen.
Wenn eine Kuh eine Senkscheide hat,
wird das Sperma abgetötet.
Sperma und Urin verträgt sich nicht.
- Ja?
Wenn eine Kuh pinkelt,
macht sie ja einen Buckel.
Wenn der Urin
nicht ganz herausfliesst ...
... und das Becken
eine leichte Fehlstellung hat ...
Landwirte sind jeweils
ziemlich interessiert und wissen,
was los ist.
Das ist gut.
* Lachen *
Wir sind doch alle Tiere.
Ja.
- Genau.
Zurzeit leben die angehenden Eltern
noch in diesem Chalet in Saanen.
Ich habe noch nicht so viel.
Aber das kommt noch.
Ein paar Kleider habe schon.
Das Wichtigste für die ersten
paar Monate habe ich bereits.
Ich beginne langsam,
mich darauf zu freuen.
Ich halte gern
nach Babysachen Ausschau.
Ich schaue mich schon
ein bisschen um
und langsam
kommt bei mir Freude auf.
Ich freue mich darauf,
das Baby in den Armen zu halten.
Vorher wollen sie noch heiraten -
im kleinen Rahmen.
Ich bin eine eher schlichte Person.
Ich brauche kein Bling-Bling
oder so was.
Ich bin unkompliziert.
Ich bin nicht der Prinzessinnentyp.
Ein Sommerrock
wäre eine Möglichkeit.
Für die Hochzeit will sich Eliane
kein neues Kleid kaufen.
Vielleicht passt mir noch ein Kleid.
Ich möchte eigentlich nicht
so viel Geld für mich ausgeben.
Ich gebe lieber
mehr für das Kind aus.
15 Autominuten von Eliane entfernt
macht sich Hebamme Chantal Boschung
bereit für einen Einsatz.
Dieses Auto wurde uns gesponsert.
Das war super.
Zuvor hatten wir
einen etwas älteren Subaru.
Mit dem neuen Auto
ist das Fahren natürlich herrlich.
Zuvor wurde es hier oben
als Taxi eingesetzt.
Der Vater einer Wöchnerin,
die bei uns war, schenkte es uns.
Wahrscheinlich das Strässchen dort.
Für das kleine Geburtshaus,
das permanent Geldsorgen hat,
ein willkommenes Geschenk.
Entschuldigung, ihr beiden.
Hallo.
Die Hebamme ist unterwegs
zu einem Wochenbettbesuch
auf einer abgelegenen Alp.
* Kuhglocken *
Hallo miteinander.
Hallo.
Hallo, Ricarda.
Die Alphütte ist nicht
ans Stromnetz angeschlossen.
Vielen Dank.
- (Frau) Behalt die Schuhe an.
Die Wöchnerin kann ihre überschüssige
Muttermilch nicht lagern.
Ich pumpte gestern ab,
weil ich zu viel Milch hatte.
Da ich sie nirgends kühlen kann, gab
ich sie heute Morgen den Kälbern.
Sie tranken sie zumindest.
* Lachen *
Es ist nett von dir,
dass du sie auch noch versorgst.
Ist es okay, wenn ich sie
auf den Rücken drehe?- Ja.
Ich möchte ihre Atmung ...
... und ihren Puls auszählen.
Es ist ideal,
wenn sie dabei schläft.
* Das Kleinkind plappert. *
Die Kinder der Bäuerin
sind überall mit von der Partie.
Im Stall schläft das Baby
in der Hängematte.
Mist, tut mir leid.
Bis anhin hielt ich ihn fest.
Macht nichts.
- Ich glaube, es ist okay.
* Lachen *
Gemäss Lehrbuch
müsste man ihn nun sterilisieren.
Ich weiss nicht,
wie du das handhabst.
Ich wische ihn
meistens an Ort und Stelle ab,
nehme ihn kurz in den Mund und ...
... gebe ihn der Kleinen zurück.
Diesmal halte ich ihn fest.
Denn ich kann nicht jedes Mal ...
Ich habe auch nicht immer ...
Du kannst nicht dauernd ein Feuer
entfachen und Wasser kochen.
Das ist gesund.
Das Alpleben: Es scheint
der jungen Familie gut zu bekommen.
* Sanfte Klänge, Kuhglocken *
Im Saanenland,
auf dem Hof der Familie Schopfer.
Der Alltag des jungen Paars
dreht sich zurzeit
noch nicht um den Nachwuchs.
Schopfers wollen mit den Tieren
auf die Voralp.
Eliane ist jetzt
im siebten Monat und topfit.
Los, geh rein. Komm.
* Eliane ächzt. *
Komm, los.
Wenn sie sich bücken muss ...
... hat sie ein bisschen Mühe.
Nicht rauskommen!
* Eliane stöhnt frustriert. *
Komm.
Auch Heidi, Marcos Mutter,
packt mit an.
Komm.
- (Heidi) Etwas bockig.
So, komm jetzt.
Schopfers möchten bald den Hof
an Marco und Eliane übergeben.
Doch das Vorhaben
ist ins Stocken geraten.
Rein.
* Sie stöhnt frustriert. *
Die Hofübergabe ist umstritten.
Momentan ist es
in der Familie etwas schwierig,
da die Hofübergabe ansteht.
Einer meiner Brüder hat das Gefühl,
er würde zu kurz kommen.
So was ist immer schwierig.
Auch für die Eltern.
Für sie ist es noch schwieriger,
weil sie immer
zwischen den Fronten sind.
Sie wollen, dass der Hof
weiterbewirtschaftet wird
und wollen ihren Kindern
gerecht werden.
Das ist eine extreme Gratwanderung.
Ob Marco und Eliane
wirklich auf den Hof ziehen können,
scheint plötzlich unklar.
Ankunft auf der Voralp
bei Les Diablerets.
Miggi, der Vater von Marco,
heisst die Tiere willkommen.
* Läuten der Kuhglocke *
Die Kühe bleiben für mindestens
einen Monat hier auf der Voralp
und warten
auf den Frühling in den Bergen.
Die Alp selbst
liegt noch tief im Schnee.
Geradeaus unter dem Berg ...
... ist die Alphütte,
zu der wir hochsteigen.
Der Weg für den Alpaufzug
sieht nicht so anstrengend aus.
Das werde ich sicher schaffen.
Ansonsten trotte ich
gemütlich hinterher.
Ich bilde das Schlusslicht.
Nein, das wird schon gehen.
Ich blicke positiv in die Zukunft.
Wenn du siehst,
wie die Alpenrosen blühen ...
Ja, dann ...
- ... kriegst du Saft und Kraft.
Genau.
* Ruhige Musik *
Eliane wird beim Alpaufzug
bereits im achten Monat sein.
Vorher steht noch
ein grosses Ereignis an.
Ich bereite gerade Salate
für das morgige Mittagessen
nach der Ziviltrauung vor.
Mein Bäuchlein
wird auch immer grösser.
* Ruhige Musik *
* Sanfte Klänge *
Es ist die Nacht vor der Hochzeit.
Eliane und Marco wollen am
nächsten Morgen ihre Liebe besiegeln.
Wir lieben uns.
Weil wir uns lieben
und weil es dazugehört.
Damit ...- Wir hätten auch
ohne Hochzeit zusammenleben können.
Wir sind bald zu dritt. Wir
heiraten, damit wir komplett sind.
Ja.
* Lachen *
7 Uhr früh.
Eliane wird von ihrer Schwester
Elvira für den Tag vorbereitet.
Sie ist Coiffeuse im Ort.
Gefällt es dir so?
- Ja, sehr.
Ist es eine Prinzessinnenfrisur?
- Nein.
Findest du es nicht ...
- Nein, es ist super.
Ich frisiere mich nicht täglich so.
Ist es okay?
- Tipptopp.
An einem solchen Tag
darf man sich schon hübsch anziehen.
* Lachen *
Auch Marco hat sich
in die Sonntagskluft gestürzt.
Sonst wird es zu dick und zu eng.
Wir machen uns auf den Weg, okay?
- Ja.
Frau Wal.
- Ja, ja.
(Zivilstandsbeamter)
Bitte treten Sie ein.
Jawohl, Sie können sich
noch die Hände desinfizieren.
Spielt es eine Rolle,
wer rechts und wer links sitzt?
(Zivilstandsbeamter)
Guten Tag, herzlich willkommen
hier im Amthaus Saanen.
Liebes Brautpaar, es ist Brauch,
dass der Zivilstandsbeamte
dem Paar bei der Trauung
einige Worte mit auf den Weg gibt.
Wenn dieser Weg geradeaus führt,
ist das relativ einfach.
Aber wenn man sich plötzlich
auf dem Strässchen befindet,
das etwas kurvig ist und auf dem
vielleicht sogar noch Steine liegen,
muss man natürlich aufpassen,
dass man nicht vom Weg abkommt.
Versuchen Sie, daran zu denken,
dass Sie beide mit Ihren Stärken,
aber auch mit Ihren Schwächen
losmarschiert seid.
Eliane Haldi, ich frage Sie:
Wollen Sie die Ehe
mit Marco Schopfer eingehen?
Ja.
Marco Schopfer, ich frage auch Sie:
Wollen Sie die Ehe
mit Eliane Haldi eingehen? - Ja.
Da Sie meine Frage
beide bejaht haben,
ist Ihre Ehe durch Ihre
gegenseitige Zustimmung geschlossen.
(Flüsternd) Sie dürfen sich küssen.
Versuch es mal.
- Wahrscheinlich ...
Der Ring ist zu eng.
- Nein, es geht nicht.
Er muss vorerst an die Halskette.
So. Jetzt trage ich ihn
halt um den Hals.
Es ist
mit einigen Emotionen verbunden.
Ich bin glücklich.
Das sind Freudentränen.
Ich bin zufrieden.
Eliane ...
Alles, alles Gute.
- Danke.
Das ist etwas Schönes.
* Eliane und Marco lachen. *
Es ist okay, danke.
* Lachen *
Hallo, Baby.
- Es strampelt.
Das Baby hat sich gefreut.
Ja.
Standesgemäss geht es
in die gemeinsame Zukunft.
Auf eure Ehe.
- Gesundheit.
Danke.
Gesundheit, Eliane,
Gesundheit, Marco.
Gesundheit.
- Gesundheit, liebe Ehefrau.
Es ist der Tag der Liebe.
Auch die Schwangerschaft und das Baby
sind heute öfter Thema als sonst.
Marcos Eltern erinnern sich.
Als Marco zur Welt kam,
sagte ich zur Hebamme:
"Das ist ja eigentlich
wie im Stall."
Das fand die Hebamme nicht so toll.
Aber so ist die Natur.
Als Bäuerin oder Bauer
hat man halt schon
einen gewissen Wissensvorsprung,
denn wir sind auch ein Säugetier.
Es ist halt schon ähnlich
wie bei den Tieren.
Es ist natürlich
schon sehr emotional,
aber das merkt man ja erst, wenn man
sich in dieser Situation befindet.
Die Hofübergabe
ist noch immer nicht geklärt.
Wo die Aussteuer später platziert
werden soll, ist heute Nebensache.
(Marco) Vielen Dank.
* Lachen *
Danke.
- Gern geschehen.
Wir stellen ihn später
in die Wohnung.
* Frauen sprechen durcheinander,
Kühe muhen. *
Zwei Wochen später
geht es auf die Alp.
Gratulation zur Hochzeit.
Eliane ist jetzt im achten Monat.
Sie will mit auf den Berg.
Bist du aufgeregt?
* Muhen *
Hey, ho!
Hopp! Komm, Salome, heia-hopp!
Komm.
Heia!
Die Kühe geben das Tempo vor -
es ist hoch.
* Muntere Volksmusikklänge *
Ich sollte nicht
abseits des Wegs herumrennen.
Vorwärts!
- Los!
* Muntere Volksmusikklänge *
Renn du ihr hinterher!
* Eliane keucht. *
Gut. Geht weiter.
Ich lasse sie vorgehen.
* Sie keucht. *
Ich glaube, sie sind schneller.
Plötzlich spürt Eliane
ein Ziehen im Unterleib.
Eine Frühgeburt
will ich lieber nicht.
Jetzt spüre ich es wieder.
Vielleicht liegt es
am Bremsen beim Autofahren.
Kaum hat sich der Bauch entspannt,
will Eliane zur Gruppe aufschliessen.
Der Alpaufzug ist heute
wichtiger als alles andere.
* Muntere Volksmusik *
Ja, ich nehme es gemütlicher.
Marco chauffiert einige Tiere,
darunter die Trächtigen, im Anhänger.
Noch ein bisschen nach vorn fahren.
Oh!
Sie muss selbst wissen,
wie viel sie machen
und was sie sich zumuten kann.
Ich höre einfach
auf mein Bauchgefühl.
Man muss immer
auf sein Bauchgefühl achten.
Die Alp Isenau: 1'850 m ü.M.
Hier werden die Schwiegereltern
mit den Tieren
den Sommer verbringen.
Nach den Strapazen
gibt's ein Gläschen Weisswein.
Gesundheit.
Ein bisschen Wein zum Anstossen
liegt drin.
Den Rest gebe ich ihm.
Während Marco und die Helfer
eine Pause brauchen,
ist Eliane schon wieder am Werk.
Ich baue nun gemütlich den Zaun auf.
Ich bin froh, dass ...
... er mir den Zaun
für die Ziegen mitbrachte.
* Kuhglocken *
Der Zaun steht unter Strom.
Auch das kein Problem
für die toughe Bäuerin.
Damit warte ich noch.
Der Stromzaun
zwickte mich ab und zu,
aber ich hatte keine Angst,
dass etwas passiert.
(Chantal) Wenn ich höre, dass du
beim Alpaufzug den Hang hochrennst
und danach noch Zäune baust,
habe ich das Gefühl,
dass du dich übernimmst
und dass es nicht nur daran liegt,
dass sich die Bänder dehnen.
Nein, nein,
nun tue ich das nicht mehr.
Beim Alpaufzug sprudeln
sowieso die Hormone.- Ja.
Ja, nun sind die Kühe auf der Alp
und du kannst dich entspannen.
Hebamme Chantal warnt:
Das Ziehen im Bauch könnte ein
Anzeichen für eine Frühgeburt sein.
Ich nehme das wirklich sehr ernst.
Sie sagte schon das letzte Mal,
als ich ihr das erzählte,
dass ich vielleicht nicht nur einen,
sondern mehrere Gänge
zurückschalten müsse.
Äh, ja.
Und so sieht Runterschalten
bei Eliane aus.
Während die Eltern Schopfer
auf der Alp sind,
lagert Eliane
das Heu auf dem Hof ein.
Immerhin sitzt Eliane - wenn auch
in schwindelerregender Höhe.
Die Hofübergabe
ist immer noch nicht geklärt.
Ans Einziehen ist nicht zu denken.
Wenigstens soll
fürs Baby alles bereit sein.
Muss das auch noch sein?
Ja, ich will nicht, dass
es im Wohnzimmer schlafen muss.
Sonst musst du,
wenn ich im Geburtshaus bin,
noch ruckzuck
allein das Kinderzimmer einrichten,
damit alles bereit ist,
wenn wir zurückkommen.
Er will immer alles
im letzten Moment machen.
Ich würde noch warten.
Das Bett ist doch ...
Er macht alles im letzten Moment.
Mir ist es lieber,
es frühzeitig vorzubereiten,
damit am Ende alles bereit ist.
Ich bin anfangs ja diejenige,
die sich v.a. ums Baby kümmert.
Wo sind die Schrauben?
- Hier drin.
Das Köpfchen sollte in Richtung Bett
zeigen, aber das geht wohl nicht.
Können wir es nicht daneben stellen?
- Nein, eigentlich ...
Ich würde die Kommode noch
weiter vorn platzieren.- Und dann?
Es ist eng im winzigen Schlafzimmer.
Nun kann das Baby kommen.
Willst du die Kommode so hinstellen
wie vorhin und dahinter das Bett?
Ja.- Ich will das Kind nicht
hinter der Kommode hervorholen.
Nein, es ist nicht hinter der
Kommode. Schau, wie breit das ist.
Ja, schau, wie breit das ist.
Wenn wir es drehen würden ...
Aha.
- Ich glaube, so ist es okay.
Mission geglückt.
- Ja, es ist okay.
Noch wenige Tage bleiben
bis zum Geburtstermin.
In den letzten Tagen
war es ziemlich warm.
Ich kämpfte etwas mit der Hitze.
Gelegentlich habe ich
unregelmässige Wehen.
Manchmal zähle ich die Abstände,
um zu sehen, ob es bald so weit ist.
Der Termin verstreicht.
Doch das Landwirtepaar bleibt ruhig.
Sie vertrauen auf die Natur.
Ich denke,
wenn es auf natürlichem Weg kommt,
schaffen das die meisten Leute.
Nein, nicht die meisten, alle.
Wir haben ja einen Instinkt,
der dann einsetzt.
Dann ist man in einem Zustand ...
... in dem es trotzdem funktioniert.
Sechs Tage und Nächte sind vergangen.
Dann, mitten in der Nacht,
ist es so weit.
Hebamme Chantal hat Dienst.
Hallo.
- Hallo.
Guten Morgen.
- Willkommen.
Du darfst gleich durchgehen,
und du nimmst es gemütlich.
Eliane hat starke Wehen.
Chantal rechnet
mit einer raschen Geburt.
Vorhin kam gerade eine Wehe.
Ich wusste nicht,
ob noch etwas passiert,
und beschloss, zu schlafen.
Plötzlich spürte ich einen
ziehenden Schmerz und sprang auf.
Ich konnte nicht ...
- Du konntest nicht liegen bleiben.
Nein, ich wusste nicht, was tun.
Das ist fies,
nun beginnt es gleich wieder ...
... zu ziehen, was?
Das Baby bewegt
das Köpfchen ein bisschen.
Du bist ...
... 3 cm weit offen.
Das ist gut.
Ich spürte, dass sich
das Köpfchen fix im Becken befindet.
Das ist gut.
So entsteht etwas Druck nach unten.
Die Badewanne soll Eliane helfen,
sich zu entspannen.
Die Geburt
ist weniger weit fortgeschritten,
als Chantal angenommen hat.
* Ruhige Klänge *
* Eliane seufzt. *
Eliane bleibt insgesamt 6 Std.
in der Badewanne.
Marco weicht nicht von ihrer Seite.
In den frühen Morgenstunden -
Eliane hat keine Sekunde geschlafen -
werden die Wehen stärker.
* Schmerzvolles Stöhnen *
* Angestrengtes,
schmerzvolles Stöhnen *
* Schmerzvolles Stöhnen *
Sehr gut.
* Eliane ächzt. *
Das ist ein liebes Baby, was?
Mhm.
- Es hilft gut mit.
* Tiefes Ausatmen *
Es ist schon hart ...
... zuzuschauen, wie es ihr ...
... so schlecht geht.
Wenn es drückt, müssen wir schauen,
ob du bereits pressen darfst.
* Eliane stöhnt. *
Alle hoffen,
dass es bald so weit ist.
Du machst das gut, Schatz.
Doch die Untersuchung zeigt:
Die Geburt stagniert.
Mit der Hebamme der Frühschicht
bespricht Chantal,
wie es weitergehen soll.
10 Std. sind vergangen.
Die Hebammen vermuten, dass
das Baby ein Sternengucker ist
und zudem schräg im Becken liegt.
Eliane ist geschwächt
und hat starke Schmerzen.
Die Hebammen schlagen
eine Verlegung ins Spital vor.
Die Entscheidung liegt beim Paar.
* Schmerzvolles Stöhnen *
(Hebamme) Weiter, du schaffst das.
* Die Hebamme
macht ermutigende Laute. *
* Marco flüstert unverständlich. *
Du hast nicht viel Schlaf gekriegt.
* Kuss *
Kannst du noch?
- Ja.
Da es dem Baby gut geht, entscheiden
Eliane und Marco, zu bleiben.
(Beruhigend) Ja.
Sie wird auf der Toilette das Becken
nochmals stark durchschütteln,
um etwas Bewegung reinzubringen.
Die Idee dahinter ist, dass
das Baby so den Weg leichter findet.
Der letzte Versuch der Hebammen,
das Baby zu drehen.
Gelingt es nicht,
muss Eliane ins Spital.
* Eliane und Marco
machen gemeinsam Atemübungen. *
Nach 17 Std. brechen die Hebammen ab.
Eliane muss verlegt werden.
* Schmerzvolles Stöhnen *
* Ruhige Klänge *
Weil im Spital Zweisimmen keine
Geburtenabteilung mehr existiert,
muss Eliane nach Thun.
Eine einstündige Autofahrt
steht ihr bevor.
Pardon.
Das ist ein Wehenhemmer,
damit sie möglichst keine ...
Wie hast du es dosiert? Soll ich
1-ml-Schritte einstellen?- Ja.
Wir wollen nicht
zu viele Ampullen verwenden.
Es wirkt gut,
aber nicht sehr langanhaltend.
Er geht nicht rein. Nein, Scheisse.
- Du musst nichts tun.
(Marco) Bei Betätigung der Bremse
und der Kuppelung schaltet er aus.
* Marco und Eliane
machen gemeinsam Atemübungen. *
Eine Verlegung während der Geburt
ist anstrengend
und kommt in der Maternité
glücklicherweise selten vor.
* Eliane macht Atemübungen. *
(Marco) Nur die Nerven behalten.
(Chantal) Weiss jemand, wohin?
- (Marco) Ja.
Ein solches Abenteuer
würdest du in Zürich nicht erleben.
Wie?
- So wie wir unterwegs sind.
(Hebamme) Zumindest nicht
mit dieser tollen Aussicht.
Unkonventionell.
Nach einigen Diskussionen
über die schnellste Route
ist Eliane endlich im Spital.
Ankunft im Gebärsaal.
Eliane kann sich
kaum mehr auf den Beinen halten.
Der Ultraschall bestätigt,
was die Hebammen befürchtet haben.
(Marco) Am Oberschenkel.
Die Untersuchung
ist noch nicht so lange her.
Das Köpfchen des Babys ist noch
nicht in einer guten Position.
Daher ist es richtig,
eine PDA zu machen,
damit Platz entsteht.
Eine PDA,
ein lokales Betäubungsmittel,
soll die Geburt voranbringen.
Die Spitalhebammen übernehmen.
Ich tippe auf ein Mädchen.
* Lachen *
Tschüss.
- Auf Wiedersehen, danke.
(Marco) Einen Katheter fürs Kind,
ein CT ...
Die Messung der Sauerstoffsättigung,
ein Zugang für ...
... Flüssigkeit und Antibiotika.
Hier der Schlauch für die PDA.
Hier ist das Blutdruckmessgerät ...
... und dort drüben der Chip,
damit sie identifizierbar bleibt.
Dank der Anästhesie
tritt der Schmerz in den Hintergrund.
Doch dreht sich das Baby nicht,
wird ein Kaiserschnitt nötig.
Die Hebammen setzen alles daran,
das zu verhindern.
Die Wehen
dauern nun schon über 22 Std.
Dann, auf einmal:
Sehr gut.
* Eliane stöhnt. *
Plus 1.
- Super.
Das Baby hat sich gedreht.
(Hebamme)
Sie haben das super gemacht.
Es hat sich wirklich gelohnt.
Nicht wahr?
- Ja.
Es lohnt sich, nicht aufzugeben
und ans Kind zu glauben.
Ihr Kind hat toll mitgemacht.
* Lachen *
Sie haben wirklich
alles richtig gemacht.
Kein Kaiserschnitt. Doch
reicht die Kraft für den Endspurt?
Doktor Papaioannou
kommt auch noch vorbei.
Vielleicht müssen wir
dem Baby am Ende etwas helfen.
* Eliane stöhnt schmerzvoll. *
Versuchen Sie,
meine Finger rauszudrücken.
(Hebamme) Genau, drücken, drücken,
den Finger wegschieben.
Genau, schieben, schieben. Super.
Genau, und Luft holen.
Und nochmals.
Genau, mit aller Kraft.
Eliane kämpft.
Schieben, schieben, genau. Super.
* Angestrengtes Stöhnen *
Perfekt.
Doch es wird ein Vakuum nötig,
eine Saugglocke.
Eliane und Marco sind einverstanden.
Nicht loslassen,
weiter, weiter, weiter.
* Eliane schreit. *
Luft holen. Einatmen.
Jawohl, super. Ja, jetzt ist es gut.
- Jetzt kommt es.
Langsam.
* Eliane stöhnt schmerzerfüllt. *
(Arzt) Ausschalten.
Ausschalten.
* Eliane stöhnt schmerzvoll. *
Ja, genau.
(Arzt) Na, hallo.
Willkommen.
* Eliane weint. *
* Sanfte Klänge *
* Eliane stöhnt erleichtert. *
* Das Baby weint. *
Noel Schopfer - ein Junge.
Gesund und kräftig.
Endlich ist er da -
nach 24 langen Stunden.
* Noel schreit,
Eliane seufzt erleichtert. *
* Sanfte Klänge *
Mama Eliane, sie hat ihrem Körper
vertraut - mit Erfolg.
* Marco lacht
und macht beruhigende Laute. *
Ich bin zufrieden und glücklich.
Wir haben es geschafft.
Es läuft nicht immer
alles nach Plan, was?
Vier Wochen später.
(Eliane) Die Tante sagte schon,
er schaue drein wie ein Maulwurf.
Ich hole kurz heisses Wasser.
Er nimmt zu wie ein Weltmeister.
Das ist super.
Daher habe ich gar keine Angst,
dass etwas nicht stimmen könnte.
Hat es sich für dich gelohnt?
- Ja.
Es war schon eine harte Geburt, aber
ich bin froh, dass er gesund ist.
Das ist das Wichtigste.
Es ist schön,
dass wir beide gesund sind.
Es ist ja alles gut gegangen.
Es war einfach ein etwas längerer
Weg, aber es hat sich gelohnt.
Süss war er von Anfang an.
- Ja.
Mutter und Kind
haben sich gut erholt.
Die Strapazen der Geburt
sind fast vergessen.
Pardon.
Hallo.
- Hallo.
Hallo, Noel.
* Er lacht. *
* Noel greint. *
Willst du ihn nehmen?
Wie geht es dem Papa?
- Gut. Und der Hebamme?
* Lachen *
Dieser geht es auch gut.
Sie hat sich erholt.
- Ja?
Ja.
Na, Noel?
Schön.
Er ist gerne bei Papa, was?
Nicht wahr, Noel?
Ich merke schon,
dass ich tagsüber noch müde bin.
Ich benötige etwas Zeit.
Ich bin noch nicht vollständig fit.
Es braucht Zeit.
Mir ging es in den ersten zwei Tagen
noch ziemlich gut.
Wir kehrten wieder
ins Geburtshaus zurück ...
... und einen Tag später
droschen wir das Getreide.
Danach war ich völlig fertig.
Ich schlief drei Tage
lang fast nur noch.
Ja, du warst müde.
- Ja, ich war extrem kaputt.
Mit der Geburt von Noel hat sich
auch die Hofübergabe gelöst.
Die drei werden bald hier einziehen.
* Sanfte Klänge *
Das Glück - es ist perfekt.
Doch die Familie
ist noch nicht komplett.
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
puretype gmbh - 2022